deutschland in der regierungs bildungs
krise reden wir drüber mit einem der
wirklich besten verfassungsrechtler in
seiner straße mit olaf schubert damen
und herren oder auf dem handy
verschiedenen varianten mal durch wie
stehst du zb zu neuwahlen wäre das eine
gute idee skeptisch also ich meine ich
finde einfach wird einfach viel
effektivere wenn die jetzige bundestag
sage ich mal einfach ein neues
wahlergebnis festlegt bestimmt also ein
vernünftig ist dann eben für alle
parteien 40 prozent
was soll sich bei neuwahlen verbessern
ich glaube auch nicht dass die leute
dann irgendwie schlauer wählen wenn man
die partner ausland will halt so
[Applaus]
ihr haltet eure chance ihr habt ihr
nicht gehört ich meine gedanken sind
neuwahlen dann wird ja wieder sondieren
wir wieder nur geredet das ist auch
dieses deutsche reden reden reden
ich meine ich würde erstmal los regieren
und dann reden dass die beziehung
gastmahl leidenschaft 6 wenn er erst mal
anfängt zu reden dann merkst du die
frage ist ja brauchen wir denn überhaupt
eine regierung neue wir haben die
geschäftsführende und wir haben vor
allem auch beamte die in den ministerien
sowie so fröhlich weiter arbeiten dann
muss ich münchen also dass die beamten
arbeiten zehn jahre heute und dann hat
er so ein ding also also ich sag mal
spaß beiseite ich glaube momentan müssen
wir uns nicht kümmern den jetzt in der
vorweihnachtszeit das sehen ja auch noch
vom weihnachtsmann die wichtel unterwegs
als märchenland die helfen auch mal ein
bisschen in den ministerien aber jetzt
prinzipiellen der regierung brauchen und
also eine eigene ich weiß nicht also ich
würde mal fragen in holland oder beiden
belgern oder bei den franzosen ob die
vielleicht für uns hier so ein bisschen
mitregieren
das hat ja anderem auch schon mal ganz
gut geklappt wie ich finde die könnten
da jetzt auch mal was zurückgeben
ja er war für viele ist ja die fdp
aktuell so was wie der buhmann für dich
auch nein also nicht zu buhmann
vielleicht eher so dass ich finde dass
ist schon verraten also ich finde als
partei da muss man doch an die macht
wollen aber wird der wahl oder
militärputsch irgendwie keine ahnung
dieses herumgewirbelt ja soooo lieb und
nicht regieren als falsch also bitte
wenn ich meine kein mensch nicht einer
erwartet dass die richtige regierung
das gab es noch nie es geht darum dass
sie dann in berlin ein bisschen
mitmachen damit wieder was zu lachen
haben
stoff für die sendung wieder ja ja ja
die liebe ist fertig wenn du also ich
meine das können die italienischen
fußballer machen dass die sagen hier
bevor die vorreiter wm verlieren macht
man lieber gar nicht möglich
ich bin ich erzürnt dann sage ich
wirklich frei
da ziehe ich den schädel vor der spd die
haben nicht so rum gezeigt die haben ja
mit regiert bis zum letzten mann wurde
nie so also also ein
aber man muss natürlich auch sagen jetzt
nochmal kroko das wäre natürlich der
untergang
das wäre für die spd politische selbst
mut und ich denke genau deshalb ganz nah
ja hat denn
wir starten schon über die kanzlerin
würdest würdest du auch sagen hat merkel
schon wieder den zeitpunkt zum aufhören
verpasst und warum hat sich nie auf
warum hat sich immer weiter also ich hab
fast 30 jahre honecker erlebt also warum
jetzt nach zwölf jahren zu den
hektischen regierungswechsel das wäre ja
wie kündigen nach der probezeit
also nein was heute machen sie kann ja
auch nicht in ihren alten beruf zurück
also als kanzlerin bisher gewohnt dass
die gesetze schreibt sind um anderes als
physikerin mit den naturgesetzen geht
das nicht per dekret die schwerkraft
abgeschafft
das kriegt sie nicht hin da brauchen wir
noch europäischen lösung also ich denke
geht sie durch die ist mit deutschland
einfach noch nicht fertig
die wird gekrönt zur god kanzlerin
irgendwie von heino persönlich also da
ja angela die erste und die letzte
also ich sag mal so 15 jahre übrig 30
arnica frau mergen kommt ja auch aus dem
osten also auf 50 jahre alte männchen
einstellen zu viel zeit muss sein
und auch schon
[Applaus]